you also have television credits which
include law and order and Body of Proof
so how does someone break it to
television and um I guess just you know
the same way as anything else you know I
mean you you know you have to have
representation and get you appointment
television cast much quicker it feels so
you know where as I can see a breakdown
for film and trying to reach out to the
casting director or the director or
producer whatever it is to try to get
ahold of somebody knows a can i audition
or whatever if you don't have an agent
um more television it's not as simple
because you know they get to break down
today they need to release the
breakdowns so people are submitting
tomorrow they're taking all the people
they're submitting putting them into a
file to audition them on Wednesday you
know like the next day and then my
thursday its cast and friday at shooting
you know i mean it's such a fast pace
thing so you know having an agent's
really crucial in that situation for
sure and you know there are things that
like you know different cast and
director workshops and stuff around town
that people go to I I've gone to a few
as well and you know dirt there are
offices that I would go into all the
time and then I realized I haven't been
there like a month or two and then I see
that they're gonna be doing like casting
director workshop so I'll pop in just to
do a scene and sort of just remind them
that you exist you know that you're
still doing it and you know because it's
so easy I mean we all know I mean I
don't want we're casting our projects
you know I have millions of friends who
are actors and I want to cast him in all
the stuff that I do and the minute as
thing comes up that I have to cast and
I'm like I don't know anybody like I
don't know anybody I can't think of
anybody you know I mean the pressure
comes on I'm like who you know you
forget everybody and it's not a personal
thing it's just sometimes like you know
there's something things going on so I
understand when you're casting a
television show or a TV you know our
movie i should say um you're dealing
with even on a bigger level you know so
sometimes just seeing them they remember
that you exist that you're around like
oh perfectly we can bring aches for this
tomorrow you know or whatever so you
know television is a different medium
for sure and in terms of like technical
stuff like skills sets like I mean it
moves quicker so I think you need to be
on your stuff you know and know and like
you know they know what they're casting
if they're looking for you know for this
they're not going to bring it it's not
lie
you know the odds of likes like them
bringing in charlize theron for monster
on but like the television version is
very slim because they don't have much
time for for all this stuff you know
what I mean like in a movie you can do
you know make up for hours and you're
working for months to like build that
character and let her put on weight or
whatever she did for the movie but in TV
it's like we gotta show you tomorrow you
can't put on 50 pounds overnight or
whatever it is you know so I think it's
also different in that regard you know
like they look a little bit more for
their types like you know like actors
like to use the word and we always
getting typecast and like TVs a big one
of those you know you if you're this and
you're probably gonna play this or this
because those are the quickest things
that you can do you know so i think i
think for television knowing what you
you can know what you are and what your
product is what you're selling and how
you can sort of fit into a TV show like
that's important you know like i'm not
going to go audition for iCarly because
it's not really sure i'm probably
appropriate for whether it's age or or
you know whatever I you know I don't
really watch ICarly what's the first
thing that popped in my head but you
know like no you know know that if a
show is you know um if it's the george
lopez show and you're not Latin you know
your odds of getting on that show are
probably not the best you know what I
mean like target specific shows that
you're right for you know so I think
knowing you know knowing your product
what you're selling is really important
for television because it's it's so
specific to that to that type
you